do you regret it all in the same music
no because I just thought of it that
that interview that you did that went
viral and and at everything you don't
man in Canada oh yeah
do you regret that you got it so visibly
annoyed or was it the exact same thing
that you were trying to do your music
and it wasn't well no respect was weird
about it was that I was vilified and and
not this cat that's why I didn't
understand it's like because you know
the way they write about that incident
which is first of all I couldn't believe
it was news and the second thing is that
supposedly I went on a rant and I barely
was audible you didn't say I was just
kind of sitting there I mean you know I
went nuts and I was on drugs and all he
say it's like no that didn't happen
right you know you didn't see what
really happened what happened went on
before you know and all I was saying was
I'll talk about whatever you want I
don't care I'll talk about I don't mind
talking about movies all I said was can
you do me a favor because it says on
your teleprompter there that you're
gonna introduce this as Academy
award-winning actor is here with his
band and I said would you show some
props to my guys here and just introduce
us as the band and then let's talk about
that that's all I said Wow that's all I
said
and said and they said yeah sure no
problem and then I saw that they didn't
take it off there and I said again look
them could you tell the guy to the
producer could you tell the guy just
make sure oh yeah that's just for
reference don't worry about it we'll
never do that to you
first thing looks me right in the eyes
is like basically like I'm gonna say it
however I want to and so that's what
happened that makes not and so instead
of you know walking off or storming out
or saying something about that I just
decided well you know what I'll just
answer your questions with other answers
yeah I can [ __ ] with you two then you
know yeah it was one of those things
it's like if a dude comes up to you and
just says here I'm going to knock the
rock off your shoulder and then you know
I'll pee on your shoes when people
aren't looking you know yeah exactly why
do that when my face is available
exactly but it was very simple yeah
make sense yeah and he and I saw him
later on and he came he was very nice to
me said you know what
kind of made peace over okay yet